I do wake up looking like this - the
shirt and the pants I love I learned
that where the beaches are hot and the
people are even hotter but what will
these Islanders do when others come in
to steal their newfound boo this is love
after the island
[Music]
hey beaches welcome to love after the
island your official love island after
show though this episode is actually a
pre-show
I'm your host lauren zima here with all
the deeds on the international sensation
invading your TV screens this summer
only on CBS and CBS all access so how
does love island work exactly the love
game starts with five guys and five
girls the Islanders and it's important
to note that everyone is like really
really really good-looking equally hot
is the backdrop a casual villa in
fabulous Fiji the cast couples up via
their own choosing and these couples are
stuck with each other for five weeks the
final couple standing together at the
end wins the competition but here's the
thing this is a reality show and we need
the real drama so not only do the
couples have to try to make things work
together as the show goes on new
Islanders also arrive a meaning cue more
beautiful people yeah that'll shake
things up the couples compete in various
challenges they go on dates swap
partners and so much more and they have
to continuously decide if they want to
stay together if you end up single
you're in danger of elimination plus
there are several ways for people to
leave the sandy shores throughout the
competition and they are all deliciously
savaged by other couples who may want to
try to overthrow a power pair and by you
the viewer through nationwide vote the
eliminated individuals are sent home
back to their lonesome villainous lives
but there's more to these stunning
singles than just their pretty faces and
rocking bods here's what the Islanders
told only et about why they're looking
for love on TV ladies first I don't
really have a game plan I'm just kind of
looking for to see if the right guy
comes in and then if he does I'll you
know shoot my shot from there the most
important thing of me
being loved island is to find love like
I really couldn't care about the money
like if you find the person that you
love you can make money together that's
how I see it
so Love Wins share if I meet an Islander
and he has facial hair and he's you know
perfect for me he has to shave it my
love life being played out on national
TV it's it's scary you know like it's a
little scary I've only been with one guy
fully so like I can be a little timid
with things there's nothing wrong with
having a little bit of fun you know this
is a great opportunity there's hot men
around there's more to come even when
things don't work out therefore just
keep smiling but don't don't frown cuz
frowning it brings wrinkles and it's not
cute
my plan for finding love is going on
love island I just feel like why not now
I'm 26
go on TV to find love in my life on love
island why not
so whether it's for money love fame fun
or facial hair it's all happening on
love island
now let's hear it from the boys I wanted
to come on love island because I'm on
what you might call the rebound the idea
of being on a beautiful island with a
bunch of beautiful ladies was just too
good to turn down my plan for finding
love i scoped out the honey's I'm gonna
be looking for them I'm gonna look but
I'm also gonna you know get to know them
and find out which one I like because
personality is important I feel like
first off you'll win the money if you
find love so the strategy is to find
love so it's just going in there being
myself being me getting to know all the
girls and really just being genuine
honey my biggest fear about being on the
island is walking out no girl stepping
forward to me for me yeah
that'd be kind of but my strategy for
winning love is to make them love me and
that's quite easy I'll just be myself
I'm gonna be super funny gonna be super
kind now I'm gonna be nothing but ears
man it's tough being perfect uh can't
wait for this tune in to love Island
five nights a week only on CBS and
CBS all access and things start tonight
yes you have to watch it five nights a
week you guys it's totally addictive and
puts you right at the center of all the
drama plus we'll have a recap of the big
premiere for you right here on Wednesday
July 10th and then every Friday we'll be
back for a weekly keiki to discuss all
the ins and outs of love island will
have exclusive content from the
Islanders themselves and celebrity
guests will join us to weigh in on all
the tropical tea for now we filled our
love tank from our cozy Cabana here in
Burbank California I'm Lauren Zima stay
cool sexy beaches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]